what do you think about tesla and the
way they did it
like forget eon's tweets and all that
yeah yeah just tesla strategy in terms
of
uh buying holding i think it was like
seven percent maybe some somewhere in
that range uh
selling a little bit right before
earnings like just
what's your kind of analysis of the
whole thing so from the beginning i was
really skeptical that
tesla would have been a company to put
bitcoin on their balance sheet
at all like if you would have said
here's all the big tech companies tesla
would probably
been one of the last ones i would have
told you simply because they don't have
the free cash flows
that would warrant such a kind of a bold
strategy and um
by the way that's exactly why i thought
they would do it really
i've always thought that eon
the energy network uh the power wall
see i never thought about it from that
vantage point yeah i i in
and to be fair uh if i'm trying to be as
intellectually honest as possible i
don't have it in front of me so i'll
have to go back and look at exactly what
the tweets were
there was a time where uh i think i
tweeted something and i was like
if you said to me pick the company that
is going to be the first to launch their
own
coin i said tesla or amazon and my
thought process was
tesla would use it within the energy
network right like it's like a credit or
something
or amazon would basically replace like
gift cards or something like that
uh and part of it was just like he's
crazy enough to do it
right like like he has that element of
like
i'm willing to bet the house i'm willing
to whatever now he didn't do that or
he's only seven percent
but uh the way they did it seemed a
little
i i think it was exciting when they
first put the position on
when he sold a piece of it how much of
it was like testing the market versus
trying to cover
you know and i don't even know that i
buy that that's why he's like i guess
it makes sense that he wants to know how
much liquidity if he
you know needed to get out of it but
yeah but would you do it right around
the earnings uh
report is this week just come in and
blow out earnings
yeah no it's it was it was
but in short like the the reason i just
didn't think that it was gonna
be him was you know i i guess i look at
my own company like if my company wasn't
making money
like the last thing i want to do is go
buy a bunch of bitcoin
and then have to sell it as as i have my
expenses the following month to have to
pay
because at the end of the day either
your cash account is growing or it's or
it's
contracting and when i look at how
volatile their
their quote-unquote earnings are and now
i would say in the last like year
they've started demonstrating that they
can be profitable but it's still reliant
on
a lot of credits and um you start taking
some of those things away i mean it's a
completely different
ballgame for the company but i just
i was i was surprised and so the thing
that surprised me even more
is his energy comments and stuff that
he's come out
and the bigger block size stuff with
dogecoin and i'm thinking
now i was talking with jeff booth and
and lynn about it
and uh lynn alden and they're both like
hey he's
he's a huge public figure and he's
learning in public
and you know that's that's pretty much
the only thing that i can kind of hang
my hat
on that makes sense is is that he's
learning as he goes just like we did
right
there's a journey right and everyone
goes through it and you kind of
i think most people come in through
bitcoin or mining or
i think i can get rich on this or
whatever
and then you explore the entire totality
of an industry some of it's going to
have value some of it's not
yeah some people stop along the journey
and kind of get off the bus and they're
like alright so i found my home
yeah and then for the most part most
people go around the whole you know kind
of track and they come back like all
right bitcoin is real
right yeah it's weird when you are the
second first man in the world you're
doing it on twitter
but yeah i mean yeah i guess that's a
pretty good explanation of just
say something right like i mean if you
think back how many dumb things did you
or i say when we were first starting
learning about everything and someone's
like ah let me show you this or let me
you know
go read this or whatever like that's how
you learn yeah